[音楽]
こんにちは
つくらいなぁもっと
すごいのか人数で入れないぐらいが良かったなぁ
まあ明治の卒業生で
93年に卒業しましたやばかっと申します
私はですねえ
のご紹介あったようにですね越境 ec サイトを運営する
b フォードという会社の代表者をやっております
ちなみにです0
この前
マービーワードという車名の
由来ですが a 私が明治大学の学生だった頃私はラグビー部ではなかったんです
けれども
ラグビー部の監督北島忠治監督が常々おっしゃっていた一言
このシンプルな一言前へと
いう言葉をでがですね私はこの言葉に魅了されてですね
学生時代から今もなお
覚え続けていますで
まあこの前という言葉が私の経営
事業の経営また人生の轍が太くなっています
さて今日お話しさせていただきます中で多数引くわーるかける
の中でですね
まあ何ですかね人はこう前に進もうとか
あるいは人生で何かを成し遂げようとか
思う人は多くの人があっ
+とかけるっていうのをですねー
使いたがると思うんですけど
私はですね
シクと悪い
まずは山を引くの方から話をしたいと思います
まあ退く意向るー障害を取り除くですよね
前に進むために
私が
何が本当に大切なのか
を見極めるために
常識と思われていることを取り除いてきました
具体的な例を5つお話します
私どもは中古車の技術から始まりまして
私が重要この事業を始めた時はですね
パキスタンの方日本にいるパキスタンの方がいい
主にこの事業をやっていました
どちらかといったらまあ外国の方が中古車を日本から
輸出するということでグレーがイメージがあったんですねー
ですけどまぁかつですね日本人がこうやるビジネスじゃないというのが膨張式だったん
ですよ
でもですねー
みんな儲かってそうに見えたからそんな常識
員が一緒
ってことでですねー
まずは自分で初めて見て
その常識が正しいかどうかを
確かめてみたかったんですね
結果日本人の細やかな対応等
クリーンなイメージですね日本人の持つ
それを海外の方々に理解してもらえた事って5年で業界のトップになりました
この次は
まあ何でも後方ねへい権がないと
ダメなんじゃないかって思いがちまあもこの僕の境界にしてみたら貿易業をやったこと
がないければやれないんじゃないか
海外につてやコネがないと始めるのには難しいんじゃないかって思われがちですよね
でもそんな壁
ポッちゃう
っていうことでえっ
海外
事業の経験がなかった僕でも
まずは初めて見ましたまぁ結果はですね
当然ながら大きな損害も出しました
僕はまだ30前半くらいのときに
騙されちゃったですね2億5千万の損失を出しました
でも止めなかっ
なぜなら
国内だけで
木駅を削りあったり
パイのとりあえお
やるビジネスがいつまでも
酒井続けるわけじゃないと
結核海外に目を向けることで
僕ら日本で感じなかっただけれども海外の人が欲し
をしてくれる必要としてくれるそういう人達に
いろんな商材まぁ最初は9中古車でしたけれども届けることで喜んでもらえる
相手が喜んでくれるから授業も順調に拡大しました
鹿を
まだまだ
僕らがやっている市場というのは小さいです
152か僕に取引をしていますけれども
まだまだ小さい
世界には
僕らのことを必要としてくれる人がたくさんいるんだなということを感じていますね
海外事業をやりたいまあだろうね
はか行く方は特に海外でこういろんな活躍するのに項
勉強もされているでしょうし
海外にはどういうものが必要なんだろう拠点が必要だなとかというもの
簡単に移行を考えられるかと思うんですけど僕が海外に拠点をなんていうことはまあ
あんまり弱点を思わなかったですね
バッ
そんな常識院内小ということでですね
海外に10事業所があろうがなかろうが
まちなみに僕らはですねあのー
調布というですね東京でも東京でも郊外に拠点を持っておりまして
そんな中でも
自社サイトを運営して
結果日本発越境 ec サイトのダントツですねもうあの兄丸も前例
ついてこれてないタントつの影響 ec サイトの運営をしています
調布ですよ
物流インフラがない
まあ私ども得意の得意なエリアですねアプリか
なんですけれどもアフリカには物流インフラがないから
ec ビジネスを
やっても無駄なんじゃないかできないんじゃないかって常識があったんですね
そん中で撮っちゃいなと
お客様の満足のために必要だったから
自社でゼロから物流も気づきました
者でゼロからやったから
他のプレイヤーがついてこれてないです
結果
人口約10億人の
巨大マーケットで存在感のあるビジネスを展開できています
笑っちゃうと思うんですけど僕は英語が全く話せなかったですねー
貿易業
やっててです
でも
そんな蒸気式 in ないっしょ羽せなくったって
まずがやってみようと
やって耳をそれよりもやりたいと思ったんですね重要この事業
そこから
僕も勉強しました
が学校でて何年も経ったと
まあ毎朝朝7時半から15年以上もこれを英語のレスを毎朝を受けています
ん
この1-0 day
僕が言いたいメッセージは
こういうのが当たり前だから
こうしなきゃいけない
何かがないと始められない
そんな常識や先入観が
いらないんじゃないかといっ
思ったんですね
次に悪
つまり一つ一つトキトキ保護2
前に進むために私は大きな柱の誠意を一本一本
解きほぐして
光り輝かせることをやってきました
具体的な例を2つ
社内にあるデータを細かくン終わりました
主力商品である中古車
一つの車種でも
型式年式走行距離等々
1台1台にう数のデータがありません
それを破っちゃうよ
クルマの特性の一つ一つをデータとして
解きほぐしたっ
結果
各々のビッグデータが蓄積され
ai で最適化し
適正価格で仕入れて販売ができるようになりました
ブレない
作業を細かく
仕入れから納品までの流れには
細かく仕入れから納品までを細かく割りました
時代の注文を受けてから
海外のお客様にお届けするまでに
多くのこんなになかったんですね
このプロセスを
一つ一つはっちゃ王と
販売から納品まで42工程に分けました
分けて一つ一つの作業をシステムに乗っけます
結果
すべてのすべての作業の一つ一つが見えるようになって
問題点が荒い出され
改善ができるようになりました
こうして
盲目になっていたものを一つ一つ理由
浮き彫りにさせたことで勝ちにつながりました
ん
9とお前で
引くと悪で
を使って障害をはっきり見極めれば
何をするべきかが明確になるのではないでしょうか
出せやかけるという
相手が喜ぶかどうかもわかんないような知識やスキルを身につけたとしても
それで勝てることばかりじゃない
とことん引いて
葬儀だし
終わって光り輝かせる
ということを
考えてみてもいいかが出ませんいかがなもんでしょうか
私はそうやって前
進んできました
ありがとうございます
[拍手]